vi porto con me sulle scarpe della mia
prima serie come potete vedere ero molto
tranquilla per niente agitata questa
infatti la mia risata isterica mentre
guardo per la prima volta il RED carpe
del Festival Cinema di Roma Dopo una
prima foto di gruppo col cast è arrivato
il momento del Red carpell Quindi stavo
facendo un piccolo check per assicurarmi
fosse tutto a posto Eccomi davanti ai
fotografi che poso con nonchalance in
realtà dentro Stavo morendo dell'ansia
poi mentre me ne stavo andando alcuni
ragazzi mi hanno chiamato per fare delle
foto e allora mi sono precipitata come
questa corsetta super atletica devo dire
che è stato molto bello incontrare
alcuni di voi in questo contesto così
magico mi ha fatto molto molto piacere
qui ero abbastanza sollevata e stavo
tornando dalle impostazioni facendo
attenzione che non fuoriescesse nulla
foto con tutto il cast e poi ci siamo
diretti in sala per assistere alla
proiezione delle prime tre puntate di
solo Lillo che vi ricordo sarà
disponibile in esclusiva su prime video
dal 5 gennaio alla fine della proiezione
super applausi poi finalmente siamo
andati a mangiare in un ristorante molto
carino Ecco Cristiano che si serve un
carciofo super Brindisi per concludere
con bellezza questa serata e infine per
arrivare alla macchina Salvo mi ha
portato in braccio perché i miei piedi
costretti a stare tutta la sera in
fantastiche di coltelli tacco 12
chiedevano kita Ciao